die galernacht des Sports in der Wiener
Stadthalle soll auch dieses Jahr wieder
ein unvergesslicher Abend für den
heresport werden denn so viele
nominierte
heresleistungssportler das gab's noch
nie ja in jeder Kategorie haben wir eine
oder einen heres Leistungssportler
nominiert jetzt einfach Daumen drücken
und das hat in der ein oder anderen
Kategorie dann auch funktioniert der
Nicki für den Sportler des Jahres mit
behindinderung präsentiert von Wien
today geht an Thomas
Frühwirt
der mehrfache Medaillengewinner im
Handbike überrascht in seiner Dankesrede
mit sehr persönlichen Inhalten während
die meisten Sportler stolz auf
sportliche Erfolge sind ist früh wird
stolz auf ganz andere Dinge und erntet
dafür tobenden
Applaus vielleicht auf andere Sachen
vielleicht dass ich mich vor vielen
Jahren vom Alkohol getrennt habe das ist
etwas STZ bin hat für
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mich macht s ein neues wo ich mich
anders ausdrücken kann und ja das ist
das wo jeden nahe lieg sollte mein
treiben jemand motivieren ja sein Ding
durchzuziehen egal was das ist wenn es
Garten Zwerg sammeln ist dann ist es ja
geile geschichtte und ja ich glaub meine
Empfehlung ist nur sie nicht hinterm
Vorhang aus alkoholdogen das was a handy
vorlügt oder etc sie zu verstecken
sondern einfach sein Ding zu machen und
das trifft mit Sicherheit auf die
Sportlerin des Jahres zu den Nicki für
die Sportlerin des Jahres präsentiert
von bit Stone geht an Eva
pinkeli ein Höhepunkt in einer Karriere
die eigentlich schon lange beendet hätte
sein sollen wenn pinklinick auf Zurufe
von außen gehört
[Musik]
hätte Gott se Dank habe auf mein eigenes
Herz gehört Gott sei Dank habe ich auf
die Menschen gehört die mir am nächsten
stehen und ich glaub das ist generell
etwas wo unsere Gesellschaft also was
unsere Gesellschaft betrifft wenn wir
uns nach unseren Potenzialen behandeln
würden wenn wir uns ermutigen uns
gegenseitig stärken wenn einer mal nicht
mehr kann nehmen man auf die Schultern
und tragen ein paar Stückchen das wird
unsere Gesellschaft einfach gut tun und
ich glaube wir als Sportgemeinschaft
können da ein riesen Unterschied
machen wunderbare Worte Eva pinkenik
Sportlerin des
Jahres das ist unglaubliche Auszeichnung
wir haben in Österreich unglaublich
viele sehr sehr gute Sportlerinnen und
Sportler und dass sie jetzt da in die
schuhstoffen treten da V unglaublich
großen Persönlichkeiten nicht nur
sportlerpönlichkeiten sondern generell
auch als Menschen sch riesenehre eine
Ehre und ein Höhepunkt in einer
Sportlerkarriere ohne die richtige Basis
wäre das alles nicht möglich ja das
bundesj ist einfach die Grundabsicherung
für uns Sportler das ist einfach
unglaublich gut zu wissen D zumindestens
die grundab Ausgaben gedeckt sind und
man irgendwie durchs Leben kommt und ist
natürlich einer der wichtigsten Säulen
im österreichischen
Spitzensport
[Musik]
[Applaus]